disease eradication is a very difficult
challenge it's been tried for a number
of different diseases but it's only
worked so far for small pox which was
the first human disease eradicated at
the end of the 1970s and for rinderpest
which is a cattle disease or was a
cattle disease before it was eradicated
everywhere in the world global
eradication has been tried before for
malaria in the 1950s and 1960s and it
didn't succeed for it for a number of
reasons right now almost half a million
people die every year of malaria and
which is an extraordinarily high number
and a terrible burden although this
number used to be well over a million so
there has been progress in terms of
reducing this burden what one needs to
do is different if you're starting it at
a very high burden where everyone is
getting infected several times a year
and what one has to do when one's down
to the last couple of cases in a given
country the tactics change the strategy
change is the tools change when starting
out in terms of reducing the burden the
most important thing is reducing
transmission and providing access to
treatment so making sure that people
have drugs that work is very important
the second thing will be to give out
things like bed nets to reduce the rate
at which people actually get new
infections then all of a sudden you can
start to look at a country and see that
there's very little malaria in certain
parts of it and most of the malaria is
concentrated in a few remaining pockets
then building the right surveillance and
information systems and logistics to be
able to target enhanced efforts at those
sections of the country becomes the next
important thing it gets the point where
not everyone even in the highest
remaining transmission areas is infected
but you have to figure out who is still
driving transmission who is not
receiving access to the right tools and
making sure that you extend access to
everyone who's driving transmission and
everyone who is still vulnerable to the
disease and then in the end it becomes
very interesting there will be only a
small scattering of cases here and there
and finding them and responding to them
quickly
with good case management ends up
becoming one of the most important tools
in the endgame so understanding how
we're a given country is along this
continuum scaling up the tools and most
importantly the information systems and
ability to deliver treatment all along
that continuum fundamental aspects of
health systems end up becoming really
important from start to finish on a
problem like malaria eradication disease
eradication in general getting rid of
infectious diseases it is very
fundamentally an interdisciplinary
problem there will be people from the
medical side of things there will be
people from health systems and
operations people who know immunology
drug development vaccine development
mosquito science entomologists at the
same time there's also a really good
role for people who are good at
mathematics people who are good at
software people who are good at data
systems and the interesting thing is
when you have a question that's really
core to your part of the problem and you
bounce it off someone from one of these
other disciplines often they will come
up with a better way of actually framing
and looking at your specific question
sometimes they might even find a better
question that actually gets rid of the
main challenge you were trying to deal
with there's a famous saying that if a
problem seems intractable increase the
scope of the problem and that actually
becomes really evident in the power of
collaboration if you're looking at how
can we in this this one domain of say
drug development get rid of malaria that
might be an intractable question but
then you bring in the people who are
good at vector biology the people who
are good at vaccines the people who are
good at data information systems and
computing and the people who are really
good at health systems and logistics and
all of a sudden you have a bigger
problem but one where you can actually
work together and solve this it requires
a lot of learning in terms of how to
speak each other's language and how to
listen to each other and how to actually
take the time to build these bridges to
other fields and
to really see the advantage and the
impact of doing this well it's not easy
it's much easier to just sit in a room
and talk to other people from your
discipline where you already speak the
same academic or research or operational
language but it is very much worth
building these bridges and and
cross-linking
[Music]